back for blood the newest game by turtle
rock studios which is said to be the
spiritual successor by many to left 4
dead
has lots of potential but it also has
lots of issues
issues that could make or break the game
so i've played for about 6 hours or so
of the beta i've been able to play all
the story levels available to us and
i've even dabbled into a bit of versus
mode for about an hour the beta is quite
short
even though there are eight levels to
play each one is around 10 to 15 minutes
so you're gonna clear the entire beta in
about two hours on the beginning
difficulty while some of the levels i
played on were with randoms i did make
sure to do an entire playthrough from
start to finish with a couple of my
buddies as well as for the verses there
seems to be just one game mode at the
moment which is essentially a round
based survival game where the team swaps
from ridden to cleaners to see who
survives
longer whoever does survive longer wins
a point and it's first to three
like i said this game has lots of
potential turtle rock studios was the
company that made left 4 dead so if
anyone's going to be making a game like
it again
it's going to be them that being said
this beta showcased lots
of issues present in the game that may
continue into release the devs are
asking for a 60
price tag and eventually even more money
with the season pass which is a little
unnerving
also the devs claimed that since march
2019 they have said that this game isn't
left 4 dead 3 which is fine there's no
issue with that but you can't make a 4
player zombie survival game with similar
mechanics gun play equipment and special
infected with both games being made by
the same studio
and not expect anyone to say it's left 4
dead 3. regardless do with that
information what you will so before you
do anything you can explore the fort you
can create campaign lobbies human to
versus games and create your loadout
like making a card deck or using supply
points to buy from supply lines the
supply line is like a miniature battle
pass where you have to go from one rank
to the next using supply points to
unlock the items
thankfully the supply points aren't hard
to come by as you unlock them after
completing a level but as we'll see it's
not that easy
the deck builder is really nice too as
you have a set amount of cards you can
put into a deck and then you can take
them into the campaign
these are very helpful as you select one
each level and find a card box to get a
random card in the middle of the level
these are necessary to surviving as the
point of the game is to get stronger as
you progress since the difficulty at
least past the beginning one is very
unforgiving
outside the fort is a shooting range and
one of the best parts of the game it has
every weapon from primaries to
secondaries to melee as well as every
attachment in the game so not only can
you figure out what weapons suit your
playstyle but also what attachments go
good with those guns
after you're satisfied you can then
search or create a game once you've
spawned in you can go through a couple
menus like picking your cleaner as well
as a variety of cards you want to start
with the cleaner you pick will stay with
you for the entire run so you have to
choose wisely as each one of them is
actually different than the other not
only do they each have a different
starter weapon they have different buffs
and equipment evangelo for example has
the ability to break out of guards once
every 60 seconds so the team doesn't
need to help him in sticky situations
but mom can revive anyone within a
couple seconds once per level which is
extremely helpful they also provide
small team wide buffs like more stamina
more health or more movement speed
these aren't going to completely shift
the gameplay as that's where the cards
come in but they're just small
nice passive buffs to make the character
just that little more powerful after the
game starts but before you leave the
area you can buy
items from the shop with copper which
can be found or earned throughout the
levels
copper can be used to refill health and
ammo as well as buy guns attachments and
more equipment ammo guns and equipment
do exist out in the world so it's not
necessary to buy them from here but
sometimes the items are better than the
world drops
on the beginning difficulty you'll find
yourself with more copper than you can
spend
the game does tweak this problem albeit
slightly eventually the rarity of
equipment like bandages and first aid
kits become uncommon rarity which means
they'll heal you for more but they also
cost a little bit more
too in the time that i played the
medical equipment went as high as
uncommon but i'm assuming in the higher
difficulties and maybe even in the
future acts when the main game releases
this will change for the time i was able
to play
i was having fun this game is really fun
with friends i'm not entirely sure how
it feels solo but i can't imagine being
too fun especially when the difficulty
gets really high and you have to rely on
bots to save you
i tried to play solo but the solo
campaign option isn't available right
now and when you set your game to
private it just won't let you start a
game
the only way to get a solo game in the
beta is to queue for a match and hope
the players leave really early on in the
level
also another side note as i noticed this
while editing it seems the game is also
entirely online so you cannot play a
solo campaign
offline which is quite said here earlier
i mentioned i enjoy the game
when i'm able to play it and that the
campaign was finished around 2 hours and
i played versus for an hour
yet i also said that i played for 6
hours in total
so what was i doing during those extra
three hours
crashing out of the eight levels i only
finished one of them from start to
finish
every other level i crashed at least
once in sometimes i was back in my
friend's lobby within 30 seconds
sometimes i'd be going 10 plus minutes
since apparently the server was
unavailable or full which was completely
false
this turned me off the game so much i
wasn't playing the campaign and merely
just being dragged along while my
friends actually played the game
apparently though just as the characters
in this game are diverse apparently our
crashes were diverse as well
i couldn't stay in a campaign game for
more than five minutes most times but
while my friend was completely fine in
campaign he'd have an issue
queueing for a versus game and couldn't
stay in our lobby for more than five
minutes it took us 25 minutes to find a
match at one point and the one time we
found one i got disconnected immediately
so i pretty much wasted 30 minutes for
nothing
speaking of those versus matches i've
only been able to get into
three lobbies in the over one hour of
queue time and not once did it go past
round two
each game i played i either disconnected
or the enemy team left meaning we would
win by forfeit
since neither team reached three points
because of the four foot win i've
actually never fully completed a game of
verses yet this is incredibly pathetic
you wait around 10 minutes for the match
to start then you wait 2 minutes for the
survivors to pick their characters and
loadout another minute for them to
scavenge around all the gear to prepare
for the fight
only for the round to end in 3 minutes
then you do it again but switch teams
you now have to go through three minutes
of waiting for menus and picking your
loadout in character and scavenging only
to die in about two to three minutes
it's like eighty percent waiting and
twenty percent gameplay which is
ultimately just not fun speaking of
gameplay
let's talk about that firstly if you
play on console
enjoy never needing to aim again if you
played the first mission of modern
warfare 2
you'll know what i mean and you've
probably even noticed it in the gameplay
already but the first clip i'm about to
show
is either me spamming or holding the
shoot button while just aiming this of
course thanks to recoil would cause my
gun to go up and past the target
the other is me spamming the left
trigger so that i'm constantly aiming
then not aiming then back to aiming
again
as like most games aim assist can help
with snapping to targets although it's
very
minor this game is very different
however
pay attention to the ping noise as the
more pings you hear the more time i hit
the target
do you see how broken that is it looked
like i had zero recoil and i'm such a
pro
at aiming that i can control the spray
pattern of my gun but that couldn't be
farther from the truth
it looks a lot worse in game two i
literally cannot tell you what i'm
shooting at in this clip
all i know is i'm killing something and
that's about it and that's also only at
50 strength according to the setting
if you want to play with normal aim
assist i'd recommend about
20 to 30 but why would you when it's
this laughably broken another setting
that needs talking about is fov
simply put there is no console fov
slider it's not the end of the world but
the camera is just a little too close
for my comfort and it's more of a
personal preference as i know not
everybody cares about the setting but i
thought it was worth talking about since
we are on the topic of personal
preference let me go over some things
that i
dislike a bit while the gunplay is
pretty good minus the aim assist of
course
some guns don't feel like there's any
weight behind them the de-gol the magnum
and the super 90 just don't feel
powerful at all
this is quite ironic since the other
weapons even the ones in the same class
sound wonderful
the other dislike i have is actually
both the characters and the special
infected now maybe it's just because we
haven't had enough time to get to know
them yet but i don't feel connected to
these characters at all
even a decade later i could still name
you the four characters of left 4 dead 2
but
talk to me a month after release i might
not even remember half these characters
names there just seems to be no
personality behind them there is one
thing i like however and that's the
small bit of lore that gets dropped
during the discussions like finding out
that mom's son was killed and that she's
still mourning his loss
sadly this doesn't happen often and when
it does it's kind of hard to pay
attention to this stuff when you're
getting swarmed by hordes of infected
but
more of this would be really perfect the
special infected bother me for a couple
reasons as well
firstly is that there's no way to tell
when they arrive other than the
subtitles
without the subtitles i wouldn't have
figured out a special infected was on
the map left 2 had some sound cues that
played when a specific special infected
was nearby which was both smart and
helpful this does not exist in back for
blood however
the issues that bother me with most of
these is that the families the game has
the infected are split into families
tall boys reekers and stingers
all tall boys are the big guys with one
large arm the reekers all blow up and
cause a lot of chaos while the stingers
attack from long range
this is really cool but especially when
i'm really focusing in the game i can't
tell the difference between them one of
the tall boys called the crusher grabs
the enemy and crushes them while the
bruiser slams his fist on the ground
causing aoe damage
the only difference i see in them is
that one has small spikes on his arm and
the other doesn't
that doesn't help me in the slightest
knowing who i'm facing is crucial to
surviving
and i'd argue it's even worse with the
reekers as one vomits acid while the
other just explodes if i know which one
it is i can prioritize them if it's the
reeker that vomits i should shoot him
first since he has long range but if i
see the suicide reeker and he's far away
i have a bit more time before i need to
act there are differences yes but not
any that you would notice before it's
too late too many times i was calling
out the special infected on the map only
to get it wrong since they look the same
literally just making one of them each
type and not having any families would
have been great
yes the crusher is kind of like the
charger the reekers or boomers and the
stingers or the spitter from left for
dead too but
who cares at this point it's practically
a left 4 dead game and i'm ok with those
infected types
so long as i know who i'm facing that's
what i liked about left 4 dead there was
only one spitter or only 1 hunter there
wasn't one spitter that spits acid the
other one spits oil it was just one
it may sound boring only having one
specific special infected per type like
that but i believe it's more beneficial
to having an overall enjoyable game
regardless with all these issues there
were
quite a few times i was enjoying myself
and what helped this a lot was these
encounters and corruption cards and i
want to use this time to offer another
suggestion
in mission 1-2 after walking only a
couple yards from the safe house this
thing called an ogre spawns after some
time it disappears but then reappears
again at the end of the level this
adds a new bit of difficulty to the game
which was great in 2-2 there's an
excellent corruption card added to this
level corruption cards are essentially
cards that change the game a bit by
giving you challenges to earn more
copper or just outright changing
something in the map like stronger
enemies this one added fog to the game
which made it harder to see which led to
us getting ambushed quite a bit
this was genius but it's not at its
highest potential take this
and randomize it i don't want the ogre
to spawn only on 1-2 or the fog on 2-2
make the fog spawn during the finale i
want these to be random as i'm going to
create
characters and builds around this
situation and i don't want that
having this would easily surpass left 4
dead in replayability as there was no
change in the gameplay from level to
level only a difficulty meter they have
an excellent tool at their disposal i
just
really hope they utilize it what could
help this mechanic skyrocket its
potential is campaign verses
but sadly that does not exist i know
there's been a lot of debate
about this some saying only the elitist
of left 4 dead care about this game mode
while the others say it should be
required for a game like this
personally i agree with the latter the
versus mode we have now
is fun assuming the players actually
stay in the game but i can see it
getting boring really
quickly the fun of the campaign versus
mode has always been about utilizing
your knowledge of the infected and the
map to create problems for the survivors
and it could work just as well in back
for blood and since there's probably
going to be more levels than left 4 dead
this seems like even more of a reason to
do so the survivors get stronger with
cards while the infected gets stronger
with the upgrade system
both teams have the knowledge of the map
and what to do and with the addition of
these corruption cards and encounters i
mentioned earlier this ultimately
creates an intense experience and i feel
like it would be a waste if this
wasn't added so for my final thoughts of
the game
honestly i would wait to see where this
goes i still stand by my original
statement that back for blood has
potential but it needs to sort out some
issues first and the 60
plus season pass price tag really isn't
helping it has a somewhat lackluster pvp
experience and
so far a decent campaign but both have
been corrupted with awful connection
issues
completely turning me off from giving
the game another try regardless
thank you for making it this far in the
video if you've played back for blood
yourself let me know what you thought
about it in the comments down below
with that thank you for watching the
video today if you're new make sure to
subscribe for more reviews like this and
check out some of my other reviews and
essays as well
if you're a returning viewer i thank you
for coming back and as always
take care everyone goodbye
[Music]
you